bonjour à tous ce weekend samedi et
dimanche j'ai vraiment besoin de chacun
d'entre vous pour être sur le pont c'est
un weekend que je veux qu'on consacre à
porter nos valeurs auprès des Français
tous les Français porter les valeurs des
républicains ça fait 5 ans 5 ans que les
socialistes ont mis la France la tête à
l'envers qu'ils ont assommé les classes
moyennes et la France qui travaille d'
po charge qu'on a complètement
désorganisé toute l'autorité de l'État
la police la justice le travail de la
gendarmerie la gestion et la régulation
de l'immigration et puis tout simplement
on a sorti leur de la France un
président de la République qui n'incarne
plus une parole forte de la France ça
suffit et il est temps de redonner un
cap à la France il est temps qu'on
assume à nouveau no valeur ce
rendez-vous 2017 c'est celui où on remet
la boussole à la boussole sur nos idées
ce à quoi on croit la grande famille de
la droite et du centre j'ai besoin de
vous ce weekend et j'en ai besoin aussi
dans cette période de la prére parce que
la préère c'est la compétition et elle
est logique et c'est bien aussi qu'on se
rappelle qu'on a une famille commune
qu'on est ensemble qu'on porte les mêmes
idées les mêmes valeurs celles des
républicains c'est pour ça que ce
weekend je voudrait que porter ensemble
nos valeurs nos idées se fassent au-delà
même des cvages qu'on peut avoir dans le
cadre de la prire pour se rappeler cette
unité et ce rassemblement qui est
d'abord le fondement de notre famille
politique alors ce weekend on assume nos
valeurs et on porte ha le drapeau des
républicains merci à
[Musique]
tous